avec nous pour analyser tout cela à
québec l'économiste clément gignac de
l'industrielle alliance clément gignac
bonsoir bonsoir et bonne année j'ai râlé
bonne année à vous aussi une année 2010
8 qui s'est terminée de façon un peu
turbulent beaucoup de volatilité
le pire mois de décembre depuis les
années 30 on en est où aujourd'hui de 7
janvier 2019 en fait bien raison d'y
accéder très relative parce que alors
qu'en 2017 c'est comme facile de faire
de l'argent c'est une balade au parc
pour le volet adulte et on aurait eu 84
session le à la bourse de wall street ou
connu des fluctuations de plus d'un pour
cent en 2018 ça s'est dissout être plus
qu en 2007
évidemment avec la baisse qui était
importante pour le moins de 15% au
quatrième trimestre est ce que vous avez
dû le mois de décembre la pire le pire
mois depuis 1931
les jeunes commencent à craindre une
récession
or ce que j'ai fait j'ai râle je
regardais depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale et avait retrait occasion que
les marchés baisser de 19% et plus et
finalement la moitié du temps humain pas
eu de récession donc moi j'ai voulu
parler de récession environ 25% pas plus
que ça aux états unis aux etats unis
parce que les fondamentaux sont bons et
on n'a jamais vu de récession aux états
unis
5 les taux réels c'est-à-dire les taux
d'intérêt de dépasser l'inflation d'au
moins 2% avec ce fait mais ça dépend
aussi d'un demi de 1% et la politique
fiscale et expansionniste mais on a
quand même des inquiétudes sur la
croissance économique mondiale je peux
sur la croissance américaine mais en
même temps vendredi on avait les
chiffres de l'emploi 300000 emplois au
mois de décembre
c'est certain que les marchés peuvent
être un indicateur avancé de ce qui s'en
vient pour pas toujours league il 300
milles du mois de décembre avec la chute
boursière c'est difficile de faire des
liens entre la réaction boursière et les
données économiques du moment
c'est difficile de se reconnaître
complètement plus de comprendre l'état
des choses il faut penser que la bourse
est un indicateur avancé mais en même
temps comme du nez comme un prix nobel
d'économie qui avait dit que la beauce
bridi promet 10 les cinq dernières
récessions et larry que la bourse en
raison des émotions et tout exagère les
amplitudes et je pense qu'on est dans
cette situation là son regard des
fondamentaux de l'économie américaine
les ménages ont en tout dépend de 6% les
profits vont augmenter
pas loin de 25 % à embarrasser la
politique budgétaire est expressionniste
et il sera encore cette année et la
petite montagne n'est pas encore très
réceptive et les banques sont très bien
capitalisé il n'y a pas personne
actuellement aux etats-unis que projet
qui va revenir 20 qui prêtera pas si le
projet de 6,1 pour le projet de scinder
route donc dans ce sens là vous avez
réservé avoir ralenti mais romain
croissance va être autour de deux points
de 2.4 aux etats-unis cette année au
lieu du court pour cent de l'an passé
ralentissement mondial aussi que la
chine
mon est très loin là d'une récession
comme le craint ou ensuite géré on parle
donc le chef de la réserve fédérale dit
qu'il ne va pas démissionner si le
président trump lui demande et il dit
plus fondamentalement qu'il est flexible
sur l'évolution des taux d'intérêts ça
veut dire quoi ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle c'est parce qu'on se souviendra
au début octobre
monsieur pas avoir justement quand le
beau c'est un sommet et dire qu'on est
encore très loin du tout honneur puisque
les taux pourraient remonter comme une
façon considérable les puits - quand il
disait le message là il s'est aperçu
je pense qu'aussi dans sa première année
de mandat l'oise et s'était aperçu que
chaque mot compte hélas ce moment là
lorsque il ya fait son communiqué de
presse sa décision du mois de décembre
il ya quand même répété qu' on réduire l
e business de ce pilote automatique qui
semblait pas trop soucieux de ce qui se
passait au niveau de la bourse
et ça a continué de tango les tellement
que la prime de risque sur les
obligations corporatives s'est élargi de
façon importante donc le y mentionne aux
gens écoutent une inflation sous
contrôle on n'est pas dogmatique
on va s'ajuster en clair il va prendre
une pause au cours des prochains mois ce
qui risque donc pas de hausse de taux
d'intérêt aux états unis avant quoi
l'été prochain proprement au mois de
juin contre jean l'été prochain parce
que gardons à l'esprit que ça monte à
neuf reprises depuis 2015 que
l'inflation est encore stable autour de
2% et que l'économie va ralentir et les
délais de transmission gérard d'une des
hausses de taux d'intérêt ce mince après
neuf mois 1 1 avant de voir l'impact
dont je pense qu'on va voir à et à trak
si cela est ce que la paralysie du
gouvernement qui dure depuis dix jours
partiel là est ce que c'est un risque
important pour l'économie et pour les
marchés
au risque de surprendre le monde pauvre
m parce que écouter on parle de 800 me
travailleur américain bon c'est plate et
vous allez me dire mais à la réalité il
ya beaucoup de services essentiels sont
quand même pas faire et sur l'état de
l'économie comme tel c'est pas première
fois qu'on voit sur 602 pour la dernière
fois étant donné qu'on tient congrès
démocrates et un président avec une
personnalité qui peut faire quand on
connaît ce genre de bidule eux aussi
donc oui moi je pense que ce qu'est ce
qui est important c'est plutôt les
tensions commerciales avec la chine et
les directions taux d'intérêt dont c'est
un irritant mais c'est pas ça qui va
faire que la beauce doit débarquer ou
monter beaucoup mais quand même donc
paralysie il ya beaucoup de départs à la
maison blanche des personnalités qui
sont quand même importante les
démocrates majoritaires à la chambre des
représentants vous l'avez dit est ce que
quand même la situation politique à
washington et un risque grandissant pour
l'économie et pour les marchés
la réponse est oui c'est un facteur de
risque on va avoir plus de volatilité en
moyenne en 2009 qu'on a observé bulles
de zinc âmes en 2017 il n'avait pas sans
doute un peu moins que 2018 surtout au
dernier trimestre mais il faut vivre
avec un peu plus de volatilité
on est plus avancé dans le cycle
économique même s'il essaie
qu'économique ne meurent pas de
vieillesse on est plus avancée la
politique monétaire va devenir un moment
donné un peu plus restrictive donc il
faudra composer avec ce donc les gens
qui investissaient la bourse il faut
qu'ils aient des horizons 2 3 5 1 et non
pas deux trois mois parce que sinon ils
vont trouver ce trou de 6 les cycles
économiques ne meurent pas de vieillesse
dites vous c'est pas mal ça est-ce que
ce que les tarifs américains en chine
viennent ralentir la chine pour vrai ce
que c'est vrai ça je pense que oui
l'idée suivante les exportations c'est
quand même important mais c'est aussi le
fait que toutes les dépenses
d'investissement c'est pas évident
maintenant parce qu'on connaît pas ça
sera quoi les règles du jeu que pour les
compagnies internationales de l'investir
chaîne sans connaître les règles du jeu
dur au dessus des terres et poêles
exportés aux états unis peut que je suis
convaincu que ça le un impact lourd
était pas aussi gré que les gens veulent
penser parce que les exportations en
direction des états unis représentent
environ 4% du pib chinois mais un effet
sur les dépenses d'investissement et sur
la confiance également un mot en
terminant est-ce que faut s'inquiéter de
l'ange
du brésil est en principe c'est au mois
de mars là que le royaume uni se retire
de l'union européenne mais je pense que
c'est plutôt pour l'angleterre qui paie
le prix de toute cette incertitude là je
pense pas qu'au niveau des places
financières
castle impact important mais seul impact
aucun doute sur l'europe
saleh un impact sur la livre sterling et
on verra ce soir colérique jeu parce que
on proteste possiblement qu'on pourrait
se rabat aussi finalement qu on est en
élection de nouveau puis ça sera une
élection référendaire
donc moi je vois quoi comme va le voir
gerald clarke peters en l'union
européenne parfait merci clément gignac
au plaisir